[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Людей зовсім небагато,
тому що 23 хати в селі.
[Сіверщина,
село Москалі]
Взагалі-то, назва села Москалі
походить з 1508 року.
[Юрій Дахно, колекціонер старожитностей]
Назва села походить від військовослужбоців,
поселенців з Московщини,
які після повернення Любецької волості
до Великого князівства Литовського,
залишились на цій території.
Центральна вулиця — лиш кілометр,
як Київський Хрещатик.
Потім ще дві вулички, туди-сюди.
Отож бачите, які хати в селі залишилися.
До речі, ця хата цікаво побудована була:
із бані поміщика Родзєвича
із сусіднього села.
Зараз хати валяться.
Тут жила моя двоюрідна тітка,
потім вона виїхала до сина.
Хата продавалась —
купили одні дачники.
Потім вони знову її перепродали
лише за тисячу гривень.
Це вже післявоєнний варіант —
хата 1940-х років.
Колись хати були маленькі,
а сім'ї — великими.
Старі батьки на печі спали,
а діти — на лежанці спали
і на лавках, і на скрині,
і кругом, якщо дітей було багато, і на підлозі в жупаку.
Чомусь у нас така лихоманка була в селі:
збирали череп'яники по городах.
І ще змагались,
в кого кращий, в кого більший.
Моя двоюрідна сестра Ліда
трохи молодша за мене,
але ми стільки назбирали,
що, мабуть, всіх перемогли.
Зробили перший в своєму житті музей:
поміж парканом і хлівом.
У скляні та дерев'яні стелажі
повикладали череп'яники,
перед тим перемили їх всі.
Дарувати — рідко хто дарував,
хоча були винятки,
а так переважно міняли або заробляли.
Якщо треба допомогти комусь чимось...
Наші люди грошима брали,
а я — експонатами.
Є місцеві і немісцеві експонати.
Як виняток в мене — картини.
Якщо побачу десь, то можу купити.
Загалом я стараюсь,
щоб експонати були свої.
Знаю, кому належали 90% експонатів,
чиї вони і з ким пов'язані.
Нічого зі своєї колекції не продавав.
Було таке що, чернігівському музею
дарував рушника одного, в них не було.
Шкільному музею щось дарував.
Але продавати — нічого не продавав,
хоча охочих купити було достатньо.
Я працював 25 років
начальником поштового віділення,
то є спілкування з людьми.
Багато знав.
Я не тільки експонати збирав,
а й фольклор записував.
Різні бувальщини, історії,
може і сільські анекдоти.
Багато крадіїв було,
конокрадіїв було багато,
тому доводилось коней плутати,
замикали замком.
У нас селі була історія:
дуже розійшлися конокради,
господар завів коня у комору
і сам поряд спати ліг.
Бруджу накинув на коня.
І він каже, що спить...
Хвидір його звали.
Спить, і спросоння чує: «Прр-ппр».
Вже жеребця зову,
бо кінь же бідовий такий.
Зайшла жінка Горпина вранці
в комору і каже:
«Аброць на тєрніце [знаряддя для м'яття льону або конопель] лежить,
коня немає, а він спить "Прр-прр-прр" спросоння».
Каже: «Коня вивели, і не чув коли».
Тут була крамниця, яка років десять пустувала.
Купив її за власний кошт, трохи розширив
колекцію і розмістив її тут.
Так, проходьте.
Я переважно для себе музей створюю,
це моя віддушина.
Я зайду...
Багато в житті різних моментів
трапляється.
Я зайду, доторкнусь...
Може для когось це негатив,
а для мене — позитив.
Іди...
От звідки ще експонати беруться:
поховали родичку в сусідньому селі.
Оце щойно рамка з картиною, бачите?
Рамка з фотографією стояла в хаті.
Стали рамку розбирати,
а за вставною дощечкою —
така картина.
Шевченківська тема: тополя..
«Іди, доню», — каже мати,
«Не вік дівувати».
Оце качалка.
Щойно в Фейсбуці хтось запитує,
що це таке.
Це ж, розумієте, щоб прасувати.
Полотняні речі взагалі важко
праскою прасувати.
А на качалку намотується,
і потім вже...
Щоправда, ослон [лавка] повинен бути ширше.
Що ж я хочу показати?
Бачите — змія,
ручка у вигляді змії.
Очі...
Змія — це давній символ.
Змія асоціюється з ниткою, з мотузкою.
А ще ось така штука цікава може...
Пряля сідала на «дно»,
тягнула нитку.
Теж бачите — змія.
Змія, а чому ?
Кажуть, що в нашій місцевості це
зберігалося
у вигляді змії ("дніща" з оздобою)
або у вигляді жіночого обличчя.
Це був оберіг невістки від свекрухи.
Щоб невістка своєю майстерністю, своїм вмінням
прищемила свекрусі-зміюці хвіст
або заткнула рот.
Лампи, бачите.
Це — мухоловки.
Сироватку засипали,
або (я в Куприна читав) пиво.
Потім тут пробочка затулялась.
Мухи залітали під низом.
Бачите, вона на ніжках.
Жу-жу і топились туди.
Ось тут два робочі
ткацькі станки.
Кажуть, що раніше чоловіки ткали,
а не жінки.
До речі, мій прадід Дахно Анрій Гнатович
і вишивав, і ткав.
Я теж вишивати можу
і трохи ткати.
1976 року міняли опори електроенергії
у нашому окрузі.
Всюди поставили цеметові, а в нас — дерев'яні.
Сказали, що села через 20 років
не буде вже.
Так от довелось цього року
наново міняти опори.
Село живе.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор, Наталка Панченко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Ліза Литвиненко]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
DakhaBrakha, Sasha Boole]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]